oK we've promised you Hollywood stars
tonight and it doesn't get more iconic
than this man what an honor it is to
introduce one of the greatest screen
actors of all time a living legend mr.
Kirk Douglas
thank you
okay thank you very much and I wouldn't
Hank
James thank you
he looks much better out of the cave and
I want to thank miss Hansberry I think
she's gorgeous Wow where were you when I
was making pictures I have something to
confess
I love terrorists woman and my crazy
above beautiful wound and now I'm going
to give you five of them the nominee for
Best Actress support access award well
here they are
Amy Adams The Fighter Helena Bonham
Carter The King's Speech
jacki weaver animal kingdom Melissa Leo
the fighter
Hailee Steinfeld True Grit
you know now is the moment the moment
that we are all waiting for Hugh Jackman
is laughing I don't know why everybody
in in Austria sings a punning color
first is that laughing he's British
now we come to the most important part
I always lose now this is the moment if
I get together you know yourson laughing
:
first is laughing you know our we'll
never forget this moment three times and
I lost every time well now we have a
winner and a stir for support access
goes to me Melissa's vo
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Melissa Leo two
years ago Cheers
Spector's for frozen
heavy you pinch me what mine does you to
me you're much more beautiful than you
were in the flavor you're pretty
good-looking you stop but you later on
oh my god
oh wow really really really really
really truly Wow I know there's a lot of
people that said a lot of real real nice
things to me for several months now but
I'm just shaking in my boots here um
okay all right um thank you
David O'Russell I want to thank the an
actor's Mark Wahlberg Christian Bale he
went by run out for a second
Amy my sweet sister Adams Jack our
lovely daughters okay yeah I am kind of
speechless call he sakes there's people
up there too
when I watched Kate two years ago it
looked so easy ups
Alice ward your beautiful family that
open your hearts
I saw Mick here earlier dick shoutout
banana
alright dicks not in the room um thank
you so much
opening your hearts to all of us to make
this film I thank David I'll thank him
again my family my beautiful son who's
traveling right now in South America
join me
it's okay I'm okay Jack um my mom and my
dad and my brother and my friends and my
family and I want to thank the very most
of all the Academy of Motion Pictures
sciences their Board of Governors and
all their members how many of you are
here today this has been an
extraordinary journey and getting to
know what the Academy about is about and
first and foremost thank you Academy
because it's bad selling motion pictures
and respecting the work thank you so
much
you
you